الى ملف اخر الصراع على ضروره التكنولوجيا
وخطورتها الامر ليس جديدا ليس جديدا ابدا
ففي بريطانيا استخدامه الالات في المصانع
في القرن التاسع عشر كان معضله مناهضوا
الثوره الصناعيه اصحاب الحرف اليدويه
تحولوا حينها الى عصابات تقتحم المصانع
وتدمر الالات استخدام الاله الحاسبه مثلا
مثل تحديا لمدرسي الرياضيات في ولايه
واشنطن في
1986 اخرجهم استخدام الطلاب لها في
تظاهرات غاضبه ترفض المساس بالقدره
الحسابيه البشريه
علمنا منذ الخمسينات يعيش ثوره تكنولوجيه
جديده بين الانقسام حولها والاجماع عليها
من فريقين عالميين الحقيقه واحده وهي ان
قافله الطفره الجديده تسير الى مكابح
الذكاء الاصطناعي بات ذكيا جدا وتحديدا
منذ نوفمبر 2022 حين اعلنت شركه اوبن اي
عن
ولمن فاتته مميزات هذا الاختراع فهو
ببساطه نظام رد تلقائي على كل ما يمكن ان
نبحث عنه للمعرفه هو ليس كنظام رسائل خدمه
العملاء المسجله بالتاكيد الامر اعقد على
بساطه استخدامه تجربه عمليه تشرح كل شيء
لو طلبنا من
مقاله حول ذوبان الجليد في القطب الشمالي
ستظهر هذه الاجابه
يمكننا ايضا ان نطلب منه ان يجيبنا كموظف
موارد بشريه على اهم النقاط التي تيسر
قبولنا لوظيفه وما هو الرد
كما نشاهد
حتى ان مستوى الذكاء العاطفي غير المتوقع
من نظام الالي يمكنه مساعده مستخدميه في
الشعر والعلاقات الانسانيه وحتى العاطفيه
وبالمقاييس والتفضيلات
المطلوبه مع كل هذه الامكانيات وصل عدد
مستخدمي تشاد جي بي تي في الايام الخمسه
الاولى من الاعلان عنها قبل عامين الى
مليون مستخدم استغرق منصه نتفليكس اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات فيسبوك عشره اشهر لجمع هذه هذا
العدد من المتابعين والانستقرام نحو خمسه
وسبعين يوما ولذلك
اصبح طفره مقلقه